well returning to Greece's debt crisis
now and we asked at Charles barista
former US ambassador to the country and
now a senior fellow at the RAND
Corporation whether the Greeks or their
creditors were to blame for the crisis
if Greece didn't have a fiscal deficit
problem a budget deficit problem over
extended period of time they wouldn't
need to borrow such quantities of lungs
and wouldn't have the accumulated
deficit problem so in a sense the core
problem is that that said the last four
years of austerity have reduced the size
that it was that was required by the EU
as the conditionality of the conditions
for the first two bailouts that has
slowed dramatically slowed the Greek
economy dramatically affected their
revenues and actually aggravated their
deficit problems so in some respects the
Cure as as prescribed has made the
patient less healthy I don't think that
the Russians are really in a position
themselves financially to offer the kind
of significant financing that Greece
would need so I don't think that it's a
reasonable choice for Greece and it
would all of course raise all kinds of
other issues and problems I think in
time the referendum the choice of C pers
to walk out of negotiations on whatever
was the 26th or 27th of June and call a
referendum for the fifth of July is it
will not be a major event in a sense if
the referendum had come out yes the
result would have been that Cyprus
himself and his government may well
resign but they still would have been
back at the table negotiating uh some
sort of a package and the fact that the
that the referendum came in with the
overwhelming novo they're still at the
table and still negotiating and they
they will have the out
they have I think that we last week it
was a fairly dramatic event and it was
this occasion for a great internal
debate between left and right in Greece
about what to do but it's now over and
the government is as a sort of a new if
you will mandate from the people to go
off and negotiate an agreement that is
better than the agreement that was on
offer whether they succeed in that it
depends on the effect of the subsequent
week on European opinion and the
flexibility that European countries
other European Eurogroup countries are
prepared to offer Greece